les professeurs d'arts plastiques
exposent leurs créations
cela se passe à la galerie de la ferme
du mousseau les enseignants de l'école
municipale d'elancourt propose des
regards croisés et les élèves nous
demandait beaucoup il était quand même
assez curieux et avait très envie de
savoir ce qu'on faisait les uns les
autres
on a souvent montré des petites choses
mais
bon voilà on n'a pas forcément
toujours l'occasion d'exploser d'emplois
ça crée aussi une autre ambiance une
complicité et puis un autre regard et
puis aussi différemment que marie tacle
antilles et peintre elle enseigne aux
adultes et aux ados en dessins et
peintures décors marqué aux traits
rappelant l'expressionnisme
l'artiste a su trouver son propre style
une réelle chesnais elle s'impose en
maître verrier à l'école elle enseigne
le dessin et l'art plastique aux enfants
dans la galerie l exposé des pâtes de
verre en écho pièce transparente
fabienne leloup présente de petits
formats aux techniques mixtes
la directrice de l'école dévoile au
public ces dernières séries encore
inédites
c'est très délicat c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut regarder de très près parce
qu'on est dans la finesse du trait on à
la finesse du dessin
vos la matière d'onss et des autres qui
plus voir de près moi je travaille dur
sur la technique mixte c'est-à-dire des
mélanges de techniques de la pierre
noire du faisan du crayon il ya aussi de
la gravure les des monotypes alors que
fabienne leloup met en exergue les
matières et les couleurs le couple
japonais
inégaux miyata luxe inouï travail la
forme et l'espace vo de l'âge pour l
sculpture pour lui tous deux partagent
un atelier à la commanderie des
templiers de lavilledieu en tant
qu'artiste où résident autres artistes
invités robert le batteur le photographe
n'enseigne pas à l'école mais il a suivi
le processus de création de yuki chinois
les oeuvres des professeurs d'elancourt
occupons la galerie de la ferme du
mousseau jusqu'au 5 décembre
une des rares occasions pour le public
de juger le travail des enseignants